I just wanted to tell you guys something because I've been
Kind of lying to you guys, and I've been pulling back something, but I think it's not time to come clean
So basically
Yo, what's poppin guys so today?
We are at the airport now, and we are going to Montreal because I want to show you guys on my childhood
I'll show you where I grew up, but yeah, it's gonna be a long flight probably like six hours, but yeah, see you there
And here we are back
in my room back in Montreal
Yeah, it's quite a smaller room. I just want to give you guys a little tour of my humble beginnings
But yeah, I'm probably gonna. Go sleep sink. It's pretty late, but I just want to show you a few things
How does check out ooh?
Look at this picture. This was a high school trip and
This is me
There you go
Yeah
Then I had a little desk, I mean obviously I didn't have a laptop here, I didn't spend much time here, but I
Labeled my little drawers like this sign means
Drawings in French there used to be something else here, but if you just check out the books
What is this?
From the bar to the bedroom the 11 rules
Come on focus the 11 rules for picking up and pleasuring women
this is what I used to read and
Hilarious
And here you can see the diary
Which is uh?
Which is like a Darwin? It has an elementary school well. Let me find you the good part so here
You can see clearly that I like this girl called Cheryl because I wrote you know I decided to not care about Cheryl stuff
We're just friends now. Anyways today Cheryl got mad at me again yay tomorrow. I'm going through Cheryl's house. Hey
Man, I think Cheryl hates me again. I did a big mistake
Holy shit. This is quite funny. So I think I think I was graphing how much I like each of my friend
Let's see there's Alex Martin Gabe Alex was a 87%
That is so funny. You can see how I became a data scientist
You know Ender's Ender's even like a reference chart
100% means can share secrets almost impossible negative 20 as I hated wait is there any one negative 20?
No dick so
All right, I hope you enjoyed this little glimpse of my cringy life my cringy
What was ice 12 year old or 11 11 or 12 year old self?
I
Enjoyed reading that I'm kind of glad that I rolled that when I was a kid, but yeah, anyways, I'm gonna
I'm gonna prepare for tomorrow because tomorrow we're having a Montreal Meetup
Hopefully someone shows up. I don't know we'll see
See you tomorrow
alright welcome so this is where I grew up and
yeah, it's kind of sad because I want to go to Burger King cuz I want to tell you guys a story about why we
Should you know spend a little bit more money when who are younger, and there's like a philosophy behind it?
But unfortunately it became a freaking Starbucks, so this is they feel like a Walgreens I used to go to a lot
Yeah, it's called shoppers in Canada, but in French it's called foul my pee
it's kind like a Walgreens, and yeah, I used to go there a lot hit on a
cashier but uh
Good times ooh, and this
Used to be my local gym. It was actually pretty cheap. I think it was like thirty dollars a month
That's where I used to get jacked
Good times good times
And this is McDonald's my first job ever my first legit job. I mean I worked with my parents
Yes, so I started this job once 15. I worked about a year and a half and
Man like I was the first one in the history of this McDonald that did not get a raise after a year
It's pretty crazy cuz it's pretty much mandatory for you to get a raise after a year
But how was the only one that did not get one?
Yeah was that bad?
As you can see most of my fans are quite awkward
So what's poppin guys John was in the bathroom? We're done, so like we're gonna interview some people oh
Yeah, honestly. I thought your mom would actually be kind of cool
But like he's actually really douchey in real life like I thought he'd been talking like kind of cool
But like he's actually still a man like
This small kid he knows everything
Yeah, I thought somebody was gonna be there man
Okay, so so which we get Samba nothing no one really
Decent we've done on Joel and Joel ma
Way you guys about it. Yeah, well, baby, bro really oh fuck high sixes. See you guys
You can come back you can go back now
All right guys so that was a pretty dope Meetup
Thank you everyone for hanging out with me even though they left like you know 30 minutes after but it's okay
I don't know. I think it's cool. So now we're gonna. Do we're just gonna. We're just gonna go grab some food
you know chill do some other stuff, but yeah, see you later I
Wanna follow where she goes I
think about it, and she knows it I
Wanna let it take control
Cuz every time that she gets close yeah, she pulls me in enough to keep me guessing
Maybe I should stop and start confessing
I've been shaking I love it. We do go crazy. You're my bitch
nothing
You take me places
Back
Hey guys I
Just wanted to tell you guys something because I've been
Kind of lying to you guys, and I've been pulling back something, but I think it's now time to come clean
So basically, I don't even like getting water that much
Like I'm not even sponsored by them, but I just thought it was kind of funny, and you guys really liked it
I should like my boy better
but
Yeah, I don't really like him water. Oh and also a meet Jasmine. She's that she's like she's a youtuber okay?
She's gonna be really big really soon. I think so if you want to listen to awesome covers of popular songs
And you know what kind of songs you
Do pop but mostly a secret?
You're interested in listening
Check out my gym. Yeah. It's pretty cool
Check our channel, but yeah. Hope you like the video, and I'm gonna see you guys next time